今日の twitter あの俺を決めたからあの動画の最初にツイッター絶対一人
返すから動画の中で
覚えてればねやっぱり本当にも目に付いた人にすぐ返すからねを知らないもう
晒すからな俺愚痴書いた人はもうそろは晒すからバイト行ってきます
いってらっしゃいファンというわけですごいあの掃除機言いましょうどうでもいい動画
じゃあどうでもいい俺にとっちゃどうでもいいけどひょっとしたらあのどうでもよく
ない人がいるかもしれない中でこれは今この子らをとってコーヒー飲むといいますか
あのあの僕は伸びません一時期の迷いで乗ってた時期があったんですけどもあの僕は
もう哲幸
で方姫12階から美味しくないというちょっと好まな発想に落ち着いてしまって
最近は飲んでないんですけど動画見てるとも球ばかり人が多いからひょっとしたらあの
コーヒーなんて飲まねーよって思ってる人が多いと思うんですけどもひょっとしたら
どういうことがあるかもしれない今後君たちが年老いて味の嗜好が変わって今はやれ
ベロン純正オレンジジュースコーラ飲んでるかもしれませんが
コーヒーが美味しく感じる時が来るかもしれないそんな時の端に今回ばとっているので
皆さんよかったら見てくださいまあ俺には関係ないんですけど
コーヒーていろんな種類ありませんか例えばこれだったら優しい奄美と国って書いて
あるんですよただいわゆるべきなぁコーヒーてやつです普通のコーヒーてこれが止まり
の香り立つ珈琲なったけどむっ通って書いてあります0kcal
これが a 棟通り60%前ってこれが抵当なんですけどもカロリーオフと書いてあり
ますちょっと微妙に違う
耳かけてごめんねあまさひかえめカロリーをを振って書いてあります朝しか
でこちらが尾藤盗塁75%減案ここで僕は言いたい
コーヒー種類が多すぎるもう何か
慰安糖分とり体育ない人だったら武藤飲めばいいやたのりオフやの転倒や微糖やらあま
さひかえめボーイんですよ選ぶ種類がどうぞ何を判断に傷に何が違うのかっていうのは
僕ちょっとよくわかんないんで
かといって何かネットで調べてもちょっと負けだと思ってるんでちょっと今から僕が
飲んで僕のイメージを伝えて皆さんにどんなコーヒーがいいのかというとちょっとお
伝えしていこうと思いますちょっと
水がフィロミナはかなくてまた普通のレギュラーコーヒー飲んでいきましょう
レギュラーということた分砂糖が入っているのかたちの意識します台です
[音楽]
あまりねやっぱ糖分がちゃんと入ってるのはわかるこれはやはりレギュラーだからって
言うもあるかもしれないじゃあ次は武藤を飲んでみますオウム通って帰ってるからでは
頭部がゼロなんでしょ味気がないということだと思います
いただきます
[音楽]
9側にが一時期を受けたが気が狂っちゃって武藤コーヒーが好きだったんですけどまた
の思考が変わりました奴が抵当を飲んでみます芸当ってことは糖質が低いということは
武藤頭部がないわけじゃないけど低いですよーっていう感じですねいただきます
[音楽]
あーやっぱ中6頭と比べると全然佐藤寛が迫りしてますね
甘くてまた飲みやすいかなって思いました
お腹控えめ飲んでみようと思います
1でいい案甘さ控えめって言ったと思う
ん
いただきます
[音楽]
本当なんだろう
わかんないな奴や抵当のカロリーを植え込んでみようと思いますいただきます
[音楽]
でも微糖を飲んでみま政党より低いのかなビーツということはもう本当にリスクだそう
なイメージですね
いただけます
[音楽]
ああもう武藤寸前ぬ島で r 本当に微々たる量の砂糖が入っているのでちょっとああ
いうぐらい取れの方がどのより
あまりのか穴を開けないのかというか分かりづらいと思うのでちょっと僕が並べてみ
ましょう
5番枚がこっちパーク内のがコツですっ
[音楽]
た
こっちがあまりのこっちが甘くなるのでまぁ
無糖微糖
大堤東カロリーをで甘さ控えめ低等をビギナーコーヒーという順番の合わせになって
ますか誰得動画でした今回の結果で皆さんどの
コーヒーが甘いか甘くねーか分かったと思いますこの中間がちょっとカオスになってた
んで今回整備させていただきましたはいというわけでこの動画で皆さんにお伝えしたい
お経を図面する飲み物はあっ
これや
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ